en quoi la bonjour alors comment
expliquer ce mécontentement
et bien pour commencer certains
manifestants ne croient pas en la
culpabilité de leur ex gouverneur série
thorgal accusé de meurtre et critiquent
le fait qu'il soit jugé à moscou et non
pas khabar offs mais en plus de ça il
semble que le parachutage d'un
gouverneur par intérim qui n'avait
jamais mis les pieds dans la région
n'est pas arranger les choses le pouvoir
russe pensait qu'il suffisait de nommer
un nouveau gouverneur du ldpr le parti
libéral démocrate le même que sergei
four galles pour contenter la population
de cette région située à 8 heures de vol
de la capitale mais on dirait bien que
cette décision a eu l'effet inverse et
du côté du kremlin
on tente de temporiser écouter le cas de
khabarovsk est sans précédent jamais
auparavant si je ne me trompe
le dirigeant d'une région russe n'avait
été accusés d'implication dans le crime
le plus grave le meurtre cela peut
expliquer les actions des forces de
l'ordre et des autorités chargées de
l'enquète à l'égard de four galles
cela explique la nomination du chef de
région par intérim d'extérieur et la
même chose probablement explique la
réaction émotionnelle des citoyens de
khabarovsk et les habitants d'autres
régions
mais au delà de l'arrestation d'un
gouverneur ces manifestations semblent
aussi être le moyen d'exprimer une
certaine frustration envers le kremlin
car la grogne trouve désormais un écho
dans les régions voisines gagnant ainsi
une bonne partie de l'extrême orient
russe à moscou
les autorités suivent de près
l'évolution de cette fronde et espère
que le nouveau gouverneur parviennent
rapidement à créer du lien et désamorcer
les tensions avec la population locale
un poids merci à beaucoup pour à toutes
ces précisions